المتصف لا يزال مستمرا اذا على قناه
الجزيره نتابلان الى السودان حيث قال رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهاني الى بلاده لن تسمح لاي جهه
بتفكيك الجيش واحضر خلال كلم امام ضباط
وجنود معسكر المرخيات تلك الجهات وطلبها
بالابتعاد عن الجيش وعدم تحريض ضباطه والا
اعتبرت عدوه
للقوات المسلحه وذعها
تفكك والله تفرتيكا ولا تدخل فيها الذهب
ده كلام نحن بنقول لكم عشان تطمئنه
السياسيين من انه ما يدخلوا في شارع
القوات المسلحه
[تصفيق]
ونتكلم بصراحه
نحن الشباب
مع الحريه والتغيير لن دخلت جوه الجيش
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بشان الحكومه المقبله قال البرهان ان
القوات المسلحه تدعم تشكيل حكومه مدنيه من
عناصر مستقله رافضا العوده الى ما سماها
المخصصات الحزبيه اقر البرهان بوجود
تفاهمات بين المكون العسكري والقوى الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي
عن الطريق
[تصفيق]
بن راعيها وبنحفظها لا عدنا معاكم واحد
انا مع الشعب السوداني ان احنا نمضي فيما
يحقق له امنواره نحن الحكومه الجاهدين
نتوقع انها تكون الحكومه من المستغلين
الغير منتمين الاحزاب ده كلامنا بنقوله
طوالي قال له والله بلدنا تمشي ومرحبتنا
الانتقاليه متى تجينا حساب راجع ثاني تحكم
ما ندخل في نفس المحصناتك دخلنا فيها زمان
نحن الورقه قلبي نمشي فيها والورقه ما على
شان جاء معينه لا لا بحث ولا لا معينه
السودان